for more on this is host of the Reuben
report Dave Rubin also the author of
don't burn this country hey Dave great
to see you
John good to see you I mean holy cow are
we in a dystopian movie or what well we
live in Florida Dave so we have a
Surgeon General who's who's actually
looking out for parental rights and our
own doctor our own pediatrician's
recommendations now look just as the CDC
starts pushing out these new vaccine
guidance for kids we see the mainstream
media starting again get ready for a
winter of death more covet is on the way
a new wave could be coming you think
it's a coincidence
oh well of course it's not a coincidence
and of course the fear is you know being
ramped up with roughly two weeks before
these midterm elections and you know you
mentioned the winter of death and that's
what Biden said we were going to have
last December I think he said it a
little bit before Christmas and then
Omicron came and almost everybody myself
included got coveted and virtually
everybody was okay
um obviously there's all sorts of issues
with the efficacy of the vaccines but
really what's important about this is
that I watched the zoom meeting that
these 15 people had and it was extremely
dystopian dystopian I mean right out of
V for Vendetta a bunch of Faces in boxes
just you know saying their name and
voting yes they don't have the data they
don't know exactly why they're doing
this I suspect John and call me crazy
maybe I'm a conspiracy theorist but that
some of these people if we were to
really track their finances out
relatives etc etc they might have
something to gain because you know an
awful lot of people have gotten very
very Rich while being wrong about almost
everything for the last two to three
years yeah Dr fauci being one of them
um so there's that now let's also talk
about uh our home state of Florida and
uh Joy Reed who's not a fan of Florida
by the way she recently uh criticized
not only Florida but Texas as well we
can't forget MSNBC is the home of you
know Joy Reid and Al Sharpton and other
racebaders but here is the first of two
clips we want to play for you We Begin
tonight with Florida
which I would argue even with Texas
existing has emerged as the modern state
in this country that comes the closest
to a modern day version of Jim Crow now
just hear me out
if there is a state that better
exemplifies the rot of Maga Republican
rule than the State of Florida that the
governor has named in very orwellian
fashion the free state of Florida I
honestly don't know where it is don't
know what it is
strategy cotton insulting two of the
most populous states in the country and
calling everyone who lives there racist
I also don't think Joy has actually read
much George Orwell based on her
assessment there
I mean she's really terrible every time
I reference MSNBC on my show I always
say the televised mental institution
known as MSNBC uh there is nothing
racist going on here in Florida there is
nothing anti-gay going on here in
Florida what's happening here in Florida
is a flourishing state that yes Joy I
know you hate the f word meaning the
free word uh that is free it is free and
you make choices for yourself here and
by the way despite having no state
income tax here our public schools are
quite excellent you know 20 years ago
there was a joke about Florida public
schools because the idea was oh there's
all these old people here they don't
have uh state income tax so they're not
funding schools properly we have great
public schools here we have an
incredibly strong economy Miami which is
where I am was just voted the safest
city in the United States it's also the
most fit city in the United States I got
to get to the gym after this and and
there is there is a spirit here that
America used to have throughout the 50
states and that spirit is a pride in
amer America and that is I think our
biggest export from Florida right now
we're doing it right it obviously has a
lot to do with with the governor
um but it's also the people you know
it's not just because a politician makes
the right choice it's because the people
choose to live a certain way that's true
and I will say I think the schools are
getting better they still got a little
ways to go thanks to Governor DeSantis
he's showing leadership and we've also
seen some school boards flip recently
that's going to have a big effect but
let's play another clip here from Joy
Reid because it gets better or worse
I mean Florida has it all a law
abandoning gay people from declaring
their existence at school teachers can
actually get fired for it a law against
anti-racist policies at work like you
have to let the racism be in the
workplace or else
book bans and requirements for patriotic
Christian education propaganda in public
schools and of course a concerted effort
to make it as hard as possible for
anyone who might vote for the out of
power party the Democrats hashtag black
people to vote or to have representative
districts Florida's Jim Crow Redux
Governor Ron DeSantis even has his own
office of election crimes
now did you see what she did there the
Democrats hashtag black people so if
you're not uh you know on board with all
these crazy policies she's talking about
um you're not welcome in the Democratic
party no matter what race you are and if
you're black and you don't agree with
some of these policies you're not
welcome in the Democratic party either
also going back to your point I'm going
to believe this John I I have breaking
news if they can put the breaking news
Chiron below me I believe that black
people regardless of their color of
their skin much like white people and
Asian people can have all sorts of
different political thoughts and that
your skin color does not dictate your
political ideology there was some guy a
long time ago that used to say something
about that I forget his name Martin
Luther King Jr I think yes thank you yes
uh we can't forget that also speaking
about the leadership in Florida we've
got Rhonda Santos of course who we know
is a racist homo and transphobic guy and
his misogynistic so so much so that his
lieutenant governor Jeanette Nunez is
Tina his commissioner for Education
Manny Dina Manny D is also a Latino and
we have you know Joseph lobato the the
black Surgeon General and none of that
really matters except that we have to
point it out to push back against Joy
Reed's race beating well look look let's
just quickly go through the four things
she said that you're that basically this
state is anti-gay simply not true the
don't say gay Bill had nothing to do
with being gay you don't want state
employees talking to kids about sex and
gender and then hiding it from the
parents that's number one uh anti-racist
stuff yeah he doesn't want neo-racism
brought into the state where you
actually hire based on racism that is
actually racism and there are actually
federal laws that supersede States who
who If This Were even true it would be
it would be illegal we have the Civil
Rights Act of 1963 quite correct John
you're a fine host uh book bands no we
don't have book bands here in Florida uh
they do have book bands in California
because they don't like certain words
and say books like Huck Finn that many
of us read a long time ago and then of
course the final one was that uh somehow
we want to stop people from voting here
in Florida absolutely bananas you know
what you do have to do when you're
voting here in Florida you have to show
an ID which I know she seems to think
that black people can't get IDs I've
asked several black people they all seem
to be able to get IDs just like white
people I don't like Joy Reid very much
John no no I I think that's apparent
Dave and I I don't think you're alone in
that assessment
um lastly we have something for
everyone's viewing pleasure
congresswoman AOC is not very popular in
her home District these days finally she
broke last night here she is
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I don't know if we need to do a wellness
check on AOC or if we can actually make
fun of this she might have some mental
health issues there but let's just
pretend she's saying for the sake of the
argument here which is the the cringier
moment her Ricky Ricardo impersonation
or her dance moves Dave
I write it right listen I'm AOC I'm
standing here nobody likes me The Jig Is
up the grift is up people are getting it
nobody likes the woke I don't know my
accent just severely changed in the
middle of that uh look everyone's had it
with the wokes there's I I hope and pray
that her District flips uh there is a
chance there's there's a chance all over
the place New York might flip with Lee
zeldon over hochul I mean everything is
up in the air right now and I think the
one way that we can really model in
America going forward sort of based on
some of the principles of Freedom that
are happening right here in Florida is
that we're gonna have to basically say
you know what that moment where the
squad took over and the racism took over
and the drag queens and all of this
stuff took over it's in the mirror now
it's in the back mirror and we can say
AO see you later heyo see you later Dave
see you later my friend great to see you
adios Amigo if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification Bell